I really like to fight for jobs I hate
the feeling of suddenly we love that
you're back in the Hollywood scene
Kristen Stewart you are hilarious in the
new Charlie's Angels it's hard to
believe that you first became famous 11
years ago in Twilight but not all your
cast mates have had as much success as
you and Robert Pattinson the Twilight
franchise has a lot of fans but also a
lot of critics what happened some of the
cast has gone on to be super successful
while others have struggled to stay in
the limelight keep watching to find out
what your favorite Twilight stars are up
to these days Kellan Lutz Coen played
the graph and tough vampire
Emmett Cullen's before Twilight he had a
few small acting roles but he was a
successful model plane Emmet made Kellan
a household name he got bigger roles
after the movies but most of the films
have been total flops he starred in The
Legend of Hercules which only has a 3%
rating on Rotten Tomatoes Nikki read to
be married with a nice house and a
husband to kiss me when he came out
Emmett's vampire soulmate was Rosalie
who was played by Nikki Reed Nikki got
her start in the hit movie 13 she was a
fan favorite in the Twilight movies but
hasn't had any major role since she did
appear in 18 episodes of Sleepy Hollow
in 2015 Nikki it's currently married to
Ian Somerhalder Taylor Lautner during
the twilight years Taylor was one of the
hottest actors in the world what while
you're still human
you can't be serious by like tell me
you're not that stupid
everyone expected him to become one of
the most successful young actors he had
one more leading role in abduction but
it didn't get the best reviews since
then he's had trouble getting good roles
but he's not even 30 yet there's still
time for a comeback Ashley Greene the
lovable psychic vampire Alice was played
by Ashley Greene never have to be that
again before Twilight Ashley was
virtually unknown
after the franchise she got several
small roles her biggest role since the
Twilight franchise has been voicing
Batgirl
in the video game Batman Arkham Knight
but according to IMDB Ashley has six
projects in the works so if you miss her
don't worry she's coming to a theater
near you Jackson Rathbone Jasper was the
mysterious somewhat feral vampire of the
Cullen clan he had acted for a few years
before the Twilight Saga but being cast
as Jasper was his breakthrough role he's
had several roles since Breaking Dawn
soon he will play a creepy villain in
the horror movie do not reply it will be
his first huge role since his vampire
days Anna Kendrick you might not even
remember that Anna Kendrick was in the
Twilight Saga she played one of Bella's
human friends Jessica Anna was probably
the most successful Twilight actress she
became a household name after pitch
perfect she has continued to star in a
ton of hit movies she is definitely
living the good life after her twilight
days Christian Serratos Bella's other
human friend Angela was played by
Christian Serratos and she has also had
a lot of success after Twilight's before
she was cast as Angela she was on Ned's
Declassified School Survival Guide
she has been on The Walking Dead for
over 100 episodes as Rosita Espinosa we
don't want to kill we don't like she
went from vampires to zombies Christian
is also slated to play Selena quit
Bonita in an upcoming TV show about the
pop star Mackenzie Foy who can forget
the half vampire daughter of Edward and
Bella
Renesmee was played by Mackenzie Foy who
was just 12 when Breaking Dawn Part 2
came out Mackenzie has starred in a few
movies since including black eye dog and
the Nutcracker and the four realms she
will also be the lead actress in the
upcoming movie Black Beauty Robert
Pattinson Edward Cullen was the perfect
man for lots of girls in the Twilight
era you need to see what I look like
unlike Robert Pattinson doesn't always
talk finally about the movies though he
struggled to be taken seriously as an
actor but he's finally there before
Twilight he became a teen heartthrob
after playing Cedric and Harry Potter
and the Goblet of Fire
Robert starred in a lot of indie films
after Breaking Dawn but now he is back
on the scene Robert has been cast as the
new Batman he's faced a lot of criticism
but we are excited to see him bring the
superhero to life Kristen Stewart the
star of The Twilight Saga is none other
than Kristen Stewart Kristen has been
acting for years before Twilight's but
the franchise made her a household name
like Robert Pattinson Kristen has faced
a lot of criticism for her role as Bella
she tried hard to let people know that
she's a well-rounded actress she starred
in a lot of indie films so a lot of
people think she hasn't done much since
Breaking Dawn Kristen is in the new
Charlie's Angels movie proving she is
one hilarious comedic actress if you
love finding out all the deets about
your favorite stars subscribe to the
things for more awesome videos about the
hottest celebs and don't forget to click
that Bell to stay in the loop if you're
watching on mobile go on YouTube
settings and turn on those notifications
which is the five Twilight films is your
favorite let us know in the comments
thanks for watching give this video a
big thumbs up if you love Twilight we'll
catch you next time